معنا من بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجيه الامريكي عميد
الياس اذن كيف نفهم هذا الاعلان الان بان
اوكرانيا تضع اولويه للتصنيع المحلي
وبنسبه حوالي سبعه اضعاف
ما كان مقدرا في 2022 في وقت ان الحلفاء
يمدونها بالاسلحه
مياده هو سبب اساسي للاستقلاليه في
التصنيع يعني هذه الحرب تستهلك الكثير هذا
الطلب كبير والعرض قليل جدا هي مرحله يعني
تقصير سلاسل التوريد اولا اثنين التعهد
التصنيع والاستعمال في نفس الوقت 3 وهذا
امر مهم جدا اليوم الساحه الاوكرانيه هي
ساحه تجربه لكل الاسلحه الغربيه وهذا امر
يعطي لاوكرانيا الداتا او الفيدباك كما
يقال لتحسين هذه
الاسلحه وبالتالي يعني نوعيه معينه قابله
للتصدير اليوم اوكرانيا هي كانت ايام
الاتحاد السوفيتي تصنع عسكريا بشكل كبير
للاتحاد السوفيتي محركات الطوافات وحتى
البارجه التي اغلقت موسكو صنعت في
مايكوليف يعني هذا امر ليس بجديد حتى
هناك مصنع يصنع محركات المسيرات البيرقدار
لتركيا يعني هي ليست مبتدئه ولكن هذا
الامر يحررها يعني اذا صنعت اوكرانيا
سلاحها وذخيلتها في الداخل هذا الامر
يحررها من القيود الاستراتيجيه والعملانيه
في اي قرار مستقبلي هل تعتقد الياسحنا انه
بذلك لا يمكن استشعار اي تراجع متوقع
بالنسبه لحلفاء اوكرانيا في الامداد
العسكري
التراجع مياده هو متوقع وبسبب هذا الامر
ذهبوا مع الحلفاء ومع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الى خلق شيء جديد داخل اوكرانيا
بالتصنيع هناك السويد فرنسا بريطانيا
المانيا والولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهم
الدول الكبرى التي تساعد اوكرانيا هذا
الامر ايضا يحرر الجيوش ومخازن الجيوش من
النقص الذي بدا يتظاهر من خلال دعم
اوكرانيا طيب التوجه الان الى هذه
الاولويه وهي تصنيع المحليه تحتاج وقتا
بطبيعه الحال حتى يكون هناك سلاح ملموس
يمكن استخدامه في مجريات معركه تتطور
وتستمر يوميا الي مدى عامل الوقت هنا ايضا
مؤثر
عامل الوقت مؤثر الحرب طويله وايضا
استطاعت اوكرانيا تعديل الاسلحه التي
ورثتها عن الاتحاد السوفيتي واستطاعت ان
تخلق صناعه مسيرات مختلفه مسيرات جويه
متقدمه مسيرات بريه متقدمه وهي في الطور
التطوير ومسيرات بحريه سطحيه وحتى تحت
الماء فاذا انت امام مرحله كما يقال البلت
اب يعني هي عمليه تراكميه ولكن الذي يساعد
اوكرانيا هو جهوزيه النوهه كما يقال في
المجتمع الاوكراني والجيش الاوكراني الذي
اثبت انه قادر على التطوير والابتكار شكرا
جزيلا لك من بيروت العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي